foreign
that I'm calling the duplicates rule
here's what the duplicates rule is and I
think it's especially helpful
given the article that we just read
about when clutter can be good for you
here's when clutter can be bad for you
meaning get in the way not morally bad
but clutter can get in the way in fact
by definition that's what clutter does I
call this the duplicates rule it's
really the easiest of all the
decluttering rules that we have by the
way when we talk about rules they're
never rules they're always boundaries
that you can adjust for your own taste
but here's how the duplicates rule works
just because you use that fourth Skillet
doesn't mean you should keep it hmm
here's what I mean by that
if you have four Skillets and use all
four of them you want to keep them great
but if they're taking up space if you
have duplicates that are simply getting
in the way it's also okay to let it go
what do I mean by this so
just because you use something
occasionally doesn't mean
that it you should hold on to it in
perpetuity there are few reasons for
this one is by letting go of it you may
actually find someone else who will get
more value from that thing which could
be helpful to them that's not the reason
to let go of something because you could
let go of everything at that point but
also you might recognize that you enjoy
cooking more when you don't have four
Skillets and instead you're using just
one or two
and you can even do a packing party for
a period of time okay I get that I use
this Skillet and it doesn't fall within
my 90-90 rule the seasonality rule
I've used it within the last 90 days but
let me set it aside for a little bit see
if I can get by without it for a period
of three weeks four weeks what happens
if I go without and if you go without
and you see a marked improvement
in your everyday activities it could be
a duplicate shirt it could be
kitchenware spatulas Skillets whatever
it might be then I think it's a sign
that it's worth considering letting go
yeah
no I I like what you're pointing out
here because it's not
you're not saying this thing about the
duplicate Skillet just to
give people leverage to uh uh or give
them an excuse to let go of something
it's really about
is your life better without it right and
that's the experiment that you're
talking about and you know what you may
go without that fourth skillet and after
two weeks you're like oh no like I it's
kind of a pain in the butt because I
like to cook this one dish and I got to
get four Skillets going at once or you
know whatever it is
um that's a clear sign that okay maybe
you should hold on to that but yeah go
ahead Josh and that pain in the butt is
useful right because it tells you like
oh yeah I've added a little friction
here right now it could be that your
life is better with a little bit more
friction as well
because if you don't have any friction
you lose all traction whatsoever and I
learned that when Bex and I moved into
the the same main house together we had
all of these
accoutrements that sort of doubled up
and
it's easy to make an excuse oh yeah I
can think of a time where I might need
this and then it'd be it's not really a
just in case item because I know that
I'll use it occasionally
but that use is so infrequent that these
things end up just getting in my way
anyway yeah and so I have this
accidental clutter in a way because yes
it's a little useful to me but my life
is actually a little bit less chaotic
without it yeah I mean
if you if you go without it and uh you
can still go on living life without
having any obstacles because you got rid
of that thing then yeah it's a clear
sign that maybe it's okay to let that
thing go yeah and maybe it'll be better
if I do Let It Go yeah that subtraction
is going to bring some peace to my life
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100 advertisement free